So we're here with Paul.
Paul, why is it important
to be able to throw away
your prototypes once you've made them?
>> I would say that it's important to
throw away your prototypes because it
makes sure that you're not
invested in your prototypes.
One of the goals of prototyping is that
all of your prototypes are cheap and
super fast.
And so, thinking about your
prototypes is throwing them away.
Make sure that you're going to think
about them as these cheap, fast,
little things that you spit out quickly,
get rid of, recycle, move on.
Prototypes shouldn't be thought of
as just an end into themselves.
That's one of the things
engineers kind of think about,
not necessarily prototypers.
For prototypers, prototypes are a means
to the end of making good product.
Being able to use your test, being able
to demo, putting together a video for
VCs, for example, that kind of thing.
>> So the end goal is
this prototyping process,
rather than any individual
step along the way.
>> Yeah, exactly.